[Music]
history is the foundation of a people's
identity and when that foundation is
lost it is catastrophic this is ever
true when it comes to African history
this continent that made me the one that
I love so much has been scarred by
modern day labels we all know
instability poverty corruption but this
is not who we are three years ago I was
sitting in my CEOs office in East Africa
when those words flashed across my mind
I was working for a multinational
company and was being heavily encouraged
to sign off on financial statements that
were a complete fiction
I wanted this company to survive so I
spent months meticulously combing
through these financials to make sure
that the numbers were accurate and
actually useful then one day my CEO
calls me into a meeting she wasted no
time she looked me right in the eyes and
she said you are not doing what I asked
you to do if you do not sign off I will
destroy your reputation in Africa I
could not breathe it felt like my body
stopped working my mouth was so dry I
was wondering if there was sand in it in
this moment I was about to lose my job
and my reputation and all I could think
was this is not who we are
here I was about to be another casualty
of the modern day narrative this cannot
be who we are and it's not because our
history
cries out a different reality in one
Ellis tration we have the Oedo people
from 14th century West
Africa of people of which I am a
descendents this this city operated with
such a well-organized and sophisticated
communication channel that if the city
was under threat 20,000 warriors can be
notified and ready for battle in one day
innovation was everywhere their whole
city was fortified with the largest
earthwork in the world they trusted
their King to protect his people yet no
decision was made without the approval
of the Queen Mother and women weren't
only sought out for their wisdom they
also protected their city by forming
their own armies and engaging in battle
the natural resources of brass copper
and ivory were used to create economic
stability through threat through trade
and also create beautiful striking
artwork these people were not perfect
but they were dedicated to their values
in the 15th century this vibrant Kingdom
would be changed forever they would
experience colonizers competence in
conquering without contemplating
consequence after years of fighting for
survival first with diplomacy and then
on the battlefield their city was burned
to the ground beyond the lives that were
lost beyond the arts that was stolen
these people were forced to exist in a
different way new culture new religion
new principles carelessly scrambled into
a complex system that had been carefully
sculpted over hundreds of years it
worked like a cancer defined plans for
succession were uprooted and distrust
was planted among leaders leading to
political instability medicinal and
scientific innovation was discouraged
and devolved in the daily hacks for
survival generosity and giving
based on the seasons and the times
turned into transactional exchanges
motivated by self-interest this sad part
of this story is that eerily similar
versions of that story can be told about
dynasties across Africa be it the
kingdom of Mutapa and southern Africa
the Swahili to the east the kingdom of
Ghana in West Africa and so many other
dynasties that would take me the rest of
this talk to list the African identity
today has been melted into one messy
narrative struggle and we hear about it
all the time
inflation in Zimbabwe which is one
hundred and seventy five percent thirty
thousand people in Nigeria have been
displaced due to the activity of Boko
Haram armed militants kill over forty
thousand civilians in Mali and that was
just in 2019 now let's be clear we
should not forget the beauty the
cultural phenomena and the pockets of
progress that exist on the continent
today powerful and passionate people
African and not have put their money
their research their technology and even
their lives to improve that continent
but if we continue to ignore our past we
will perpetually misunderstand our
presence and create well-meaning but
inadequate solutions for our future now
I believe in the power of knowing and
internalizing history because I have
witnessed it transform democracies and
the evidence is in this country even
right here in this room and that is
black America nobody gave black America
Remembrance holidays or space in
American history books for the heroes of
the past black American history matters
today because people fought for it to
matter left it to some state governments
slavery would be called the Atlantic
triangular trade and
machinists would be written in as
radicals or dangerous or not at all
so when systems ignore the past by
slapping new names on old tricks and
like things about mass incarceration and
what police brutality are today voices
rise up armed themselves with the truths
of history and fight to course-correct
we too in Africa can command the truths
of our history on our path towards
progress so with that I have one ask of
everybody in this room and anybody
watching this video I ask that you study
one story from African history there's
so many good ones like the story of Luke
and Noah Limi it's okay if you didn't
catch that just Google the first King of
the Congo
he was so thoughtful in his territorial
expansion that he gave all of his new
districts the rights to protest and
reform his decisions that led to peace
throughout his reign and for many years
after or what about the story of King
Caleb of the kingdom of Aksum which is
modern-day Eritrea he would send his
armies across the ocean to protect
people who were going through religious
persecution for those of you in this
room who are not from Africa
familiarizing yourself with these
stories brings insight built empathy and
creates kinship like my girl Ana talked
about over here it's like learning a new
language
at first you have little understanding
not because the language is lacking in
any way but because of your lack of
knowledge of it as you continue to learn
more you open up yourself to a whole new
world
abstract transcendence and meaning and
you build a genuine connection so my
Africans it is time that we use our
history as a guiding light for the way
forward there is an uncompromising power
and reclaiming back those identities it
transforms the way that we see ourselves
and the way that we see each other and
it informs the decisions
make no matter how tough they are
decisions like the one I had to make in
that office in East Africa that day I
chose to stand my ground even though I
was visibly shaken my foundation was not
because that label is not who I am
I am the descendants of intentional
leaders who value justice I am the
daughter of great women who fought
mightier battles that is the Africa that
I choose to believe in that is the
Africa that I carry with me that is who
we are
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]